great organizations understand they're
just cause and so today I'm gonna share
what I call the Fast Pass to freedom
reasons reap results I've always found
that life
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message have a just cause over
to you simon Sinek also if you want to
know what simon and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
video every morning for free to help
build your confidence the link to sign
up is in the description below you get
the benefit of hearing what everybody
else has to think before you render your
opinion what guarantee do I have that
your stuff will work which my answer was
none I'm giving you a tool
I'll ask you a very simple question why
does your organization exist we don't
need you
clearly there's plenty of competition
clearly people have plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists that's
like when I talk to health care
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you but I know that the culture of
one organization is different than the
culture of another organization there
are cultural norms that wrap around the
sense of purpose cause or belief great
organizations understand they're just
cause they caused so just that people
would be willing to sacrifice to see the
advancement of that cause sacrifice
comes in many forms
it meat might mean working longer hours
giving you my best ideas turning down a
better job that offers me more money to
stay here because I believe in what
you're doing
and I want to see that at versed one of
my favorite examples of a Just Cause is
the Declaration of Independence our
founding fathers declared literally
wrote down they declared why we needed
our own country all men are created
equal endowed with these unalienable
rights amongst which include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
they were never against Britain the
whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
Britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence that didn't
mean that they had now provided all men
are equal now the real heavy lifting
began now let's be crystal clear when
they said all men are equal what they
meant was white Protestant men let's be
crystal clear but even early on during
the Revolutionary War George Washington
understood how limiting that was and he
realized that they had to have a broader
definition so he included Catholics he
banned any organizing against Catholics
and his armies and he would regularly
attend Mass to send the right message
sometime later we abolish slavery and
the 14th amendment sometime later we had
women's suffrage sometime later we had
Civil Rights Act sometime later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving to provide this
thing called all men are equal people
are equal and though we will never
actually get there we will die trying
and the obstacles may always be
different and what a Just Cause is it is
a vision of the future that does not yet
exist and you will commit all of your
energies to advance that vision of the
world that you have and the people you
want to attract both those who work
there those who teach there and both
those who come to learn there believe in
your vision of the future so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
of cents from someone else because they
want to be around people who are
committed to building this world that
does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you run and represent can have different
visions or overlapping visions of the
world but you must be clear what your
just cause is what you stand for
otherwise the only thing I have to judge
you on is superficial things it's like
dating right it's like dating if if
somebody tells me what they stand for
who they are they talking about their
character and those are the people we
want to spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for with their
purpose what their cause what their
beliefs are what their values are the
only thing we have to judge them on is
how much money they make and how
good-looking they are I think most
entrepreneurs have a just cause but they
don't know how to make money from it I
think most entrepreneurs when they get
started you're ambitious you're
Driven you want to change the world
you're doing things for the right
reasons your purpose comes in your pain
but how do you turn it into a business
how do you make money from it how can
you leave your job so you can do this
full-time and build a team and scale up
and make an empire doing good and making
money at the same time I think that's
the biggest thing where a lot of
entrepreneurs fall down and so today I'm
going to share what I call the fast path
to freedom steps that you should follow
if you want to move from having a full
time job to taking this thing that's in
your head and building a business around
it in 2018-2019 I think this is the
fastest way to start earning a full-time
income to buy your path to freedom and
start making an impact making your
mission happen pick the social network
where your customers are marketing 101
is you need to be where your customers
are so you're an expert you have a skill
set you're able to solve a problem you
need to be where your customers are I
would pick one social media network
I think people blow their brains out and
try to do everything at the beginning
you end up sucking and doing everything
in a really meaty Orca way pick the one
where your customers are now it might be
something like YouTube or everybody's
that or Instagram which still excuse
younger but everybody is that if it's a
business audience you might be on
LinkedIn pick the network where most of
your customers will be that's your step
number one one of the biggest challenges
that entrepreneurs miss in this process
is just creating the content is not
enough you need to engage you need to be
part of the community and so I want you
connecting with 100 people a day the
Fast Pass to freedom you want to leave
your job you want to make this a
full-time business this is the fastest
way to do it do you want to wait another
12 months 24 months 36 months like how
long do you want to wait this is the
fastest way to do it it's work but it's
the fastest way to do it find 100
potential customers every day use the
platform that you've connected to and
find people who are talking about the
problem that you can solve and connect
with 100 people every single day answer
their questions solve their problems
give value to them I'm not talking about
just giving them a happy face and say
thank you for the post I drew
cents give value to them the goal if
you're targeting a hundred customers
today with you engaging with them the
goal is you are giving them so much
value in what you are engaging with
whether that's a written post where
they're making a video for them whatever
the outreach is provides so much value
that they want to click on your account
a hundred people a day providing so much
value that they want to click on your
account what are they going to see
you're gonna see tons of expert content
on how you are the leader in this field
because you are posting one to two times
a day so let's go through a practical
example I want to I want this to stick
with you I want this to be important I
want you to take action and o take
action get out of your job do this live
your mission have your freedom it's so
important this is the example I would
use I look at my workshop that I do
twice a year in Toronto how to make
money from your ideas as a thought
leader great I teach people how to make
money with books speaking gigs
consulting advertising brand deals all
that stuff you're a thought leader
you're an expert here's how you can make
money from doing that if I was just
getting started
what I would do is probably pick
Instagram I think Instagram is the
fastest way it's not the best long-term
solution because the content is so quick
but it's the fastest way to start
building up traction so I go to
Instagram number one I take my social
network great lots of people lots of
thought leaders on Instagram number two
I now make content and so I will create
a great picture for myself I have a link
to my website I'll have a bio the talks
about this workshop what I'm doing what
I'm an expert in that is appealing and
interesting then I'm creating content
twice a day I'm gonna make a video every
single day and I'm gonna post a picture
since that's native the Instagram and
I'm going to be paying attention to the
captions and the description that I'm
writing with every single thing that I
post everything I'm posting is gonna be
about thought leadership that's what I'm
selling that's what I'm saying I'm an
expert in so it's only gonna be about
thought leadership I'm gonna address
different problems that I see I'm gonna
dress common misconceptions I'm gonna
talk about where people are falling down
and where they're where they're losing
themselves where they're making mistakes
I'm gonna talk about all of that twice
on my count and then step three I'm
gonna outreach to a hundred people and
engage with them in a meaningful way
Instagram easiest way to do it is Who
hashtag so I'd be searching for the
different hashtags that relate to what
I'm talking about I would look for the
hashtags speaker and motivational and
inspiration an author and influencer all
of these different hashtags have been
looking at those every day and finding
100 people to connect with and so
breaking it down even further let's say
I pick influencer I'll click on that
hashtag I'll see everybody who's posting
on the influencer category right now
I will go look at those people on their
accounts I will see what they're posting
whether it's a story or whether it's a
post and I will then start commenting on
it say this is great
but if you did this you would have more
success and I would give them I would
spend time I'll give them some real
practical value what they can do it
would be the best comment that they've
ever gotten on their Instagram account
and they'd say wow who is this guy Evan
Carmichael and they would click onto my
account and they would see all of the
posts that I had on my account they
would see that I'm doing this workshop
coming up and you would naturally engage
back now I'm not gonna sell all 100 of
those people every single day on my
workshop but I will convert a certain
percentage every single day and that
would allow me to get the income that I
need to get the freedom that I need to
go off and quit my job commit myself
fully to this business and get the
mission that I have in here right the
mission the cause the just cause and get
it out of here and get it into the world
that's how I would do it I hope you guys
do the same because I desperately want
you to go off and create that value now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question today I want to
know how are you going to apply the
hundred-person add a rule how can you
help 100 people every day you want your
Fastpass to freedom how are you gonna
make this happen let me know put it down
the comments below
[Music]
let's say someone has horrible of names
right but let's say that there's a
suitcase $100,000 cash if you just
remember the name the next stranger you
meet how many people are gonna remember
that person's name well remember
everyone right everyone and so that's
the thing M stands for motivation so
it's interesting so all of a sudden
everyone's a memory expert but it had
nothing to do with their capacity or
their potential everyone could do it
it's just but that they decided to do or
not if they wanted to it so it's almost
like if it's worth it enough where the
consequences are you know that big right
through that big if you're gonna miss
out on I'm not right the motivate
exactly because one of the things to
learning we know with human motivation
because I had did this presentation
and Bill Gates was there like we're
talking about wealthy individuals right
and so you know he uh afterwards I
talked to him I was we were talking
about the the bridge between education
and technology and I was like what's
missing was the future of learning and
he was like Jim you know the key is is
human motivation really understanding
what drives people I was like wow you
know that's really right because you
know there's people who go out there and
they can buy courses you know but a lot
of never open it exactly because it has
everything to do with Drive and reasons
because motivation is like you know like
what is your motive for acting right
what's the fuel and I believe there's a
success formula called h-cubed
that goes from your head to your heart
to your hands the people can visualize
and affirm and see things here all the
time and think about it but if they're
not acting with their hands you know
actually doing something about it then
usually what's missing is the second age
which is the heart the emotion the
energy of motion at a martial arts
instructor T let's how many years ago
you can't steer a parked car
you know you need fuel you know where's
the energy that's gonna do that and so
with people's mode fractions so simple
when people are remembering people's
name ask yourself why do you want to
remember this person's name because
reasons reap results I've always found
that in life reasons reap results
because you needed big enough why sure
get out late like Simon cynics book you
know start with why and so you want to
get that drive first raise your standard
Apple at the core is core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can not one drop of myself work
depends on your it's supposed to mean if
you want to learn more from Simon Stimac
check out the top ten rules a success
that I did on him it is the number two
most popular video on my channel and
there's a reason for it
the link is right next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there and some
people see the thing that prevents them
from getting the thing that they want